Phil: Intaglio is a printmaking process
or a category of printmaking.
Intaglio is a way in which we transfer an
image from a plate to a piece of paper.
Intaglio is based on
the fact that the image
area is below the flat
surface of the plate.
Within intaglio there are several types
or categories, or processes of printmaking
that you might be familiar with.
One is drypoint, which is a direct marring
or scarring of the surface
of a piece of metal
or another plate by moving
metal versus removing it.
When you scratch on a
drypoint plate, you are
creating a burr or a
raised metal from the metal
that you've moved.
Ink can sit underneath
that burr as well as
in the V-trough where the scratch was.
Etching is another intaglio process.
It is based on the
removal of metal through
a chemical process, etching
with an acid or a base.
This is different than drypoint.
Drypoint's scratching of the
plate is to create a burr
or to move metal.
In this case we're actually
only barely scratching
the surface just to remove the ground.
The image area is created
in a similar format
being that it's the recesses of the plate
that hold the ink that allow us
to transfer it to paper.